[Música]
y no sirve aquí están mejor ahora de lo
que estaban bajo saddam hussein matamos
a muchas personas
es un desastre geopolítico mayor y nunca
debimos haber permitido que se
estableciera el califato que si me
arrepienta del señor
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]
cuando fui nombrado director de la cia
el presidente me trajo a la oficina oval
y me dijo que una de mis prioridades más
importantes era y tras mi laden
así que estableció una fuerza especial
en la cia que sólo se dedicaría a ir
tras mi lado
les dije que ese era su principal misión
metro y que debían entregar un reporte
cada semana con los acontecimientos el
software sap
a punta de perseverancia a ese equipo de
la cia detectó al mensajero de bin laden
el hombre hacía sospechosos trayectos de
ida y vuelta hacia una villa convertida
en fortaleza esta edificación con muros
de 4 a 6 metros de altura estaba
instalada a dos pasos de una base
militar en abbottabad pakistán el
mensajero recorría de manera sistemática
al menos 150 kilómetros para hacer una
llamada
estábamos observando la residencia de
había un individuo de mediana edad que
solía salir con un prisionero en el
patio de una cárcel en el que caminaba
en círculos rápidamente y luego
regresaba al interior y recuerdo haberle
dicho a la silla que debían obtener una
identificación facial pues ese podía ser
bin laden y me dijeron señor director
hay paredes de tres a cinco metros de
altura
realmente no podemos tomar una foto y
les dije a todos
saben que yo he visto películas donde la
cia lo puede hacer
[Música]
la silla tenía muchas sospechas
pero no estaba totalmente segura
barack obama decidió correr el riesgo y
autorizó la operación
un equipo de navy seals fue enviado de
manera clandestina a pakistán en
helicóptero para atacar el objetivo
[Música]
esta noche puedo informarle al pueblo
estadounidense y al mundo que estados
unidos llevó a cabo una operación que
mató a osama bin laden el líder de
al-qaeda
[Aplausos]
diez años después del 11 de septiembre
el principal responsable de los
atentados quedó neutralizado los
significativos refuerzos enviados a irak
y afganistán dieron la impresión de que
la situación era un poco menos
complicada sobre todo en irak
creo que nos relajamos demasiado y si
salió mal
nunca debimos haber permitido que se
estableciera el califato en el norte de
irak
y no tenía sentido mira lo que pasó con
siria quiero decir seguimos luchando
tenemos tropas allá las personas todavía
están muriendo son state algunos estados
incentivaron que decenas de miles de
combatientes extranjeros se fueron a
siria para que cayera el régimen sirio
siria en order y para hacerlo utilizaban
la frontera entre irak y siria town
de yuzz de bordar esta es una de las
principales razones para el triunfo de
los de renta se miran maneras en audi
sexes of the bag
esperábamos que esas malas personas no
fueran tan malas y que si nosotros
éramos buenos fueran buenos y les
haremos un pastel de cumpleaños y
ustedes vendrán y todos cometemos una
parte del pastel
ex miembros del régimen de sadam
islamistas más o menos radicales
liberados de las cárceles
estadounidenses en irak encontraron un
terreno común se reunieron para sumarse
a las filas de al qaeda en el país
primero dirigido por abu musab
al-zarqawi luego por el grupo estado
islámico unos años después
[Música]
lo que sí hicimos fue dar lugar para que
surgiera el señor zarqaui y el grupo
está islámico
y eso permitió que los asesinatos el
caos y el terror existían en todo el
país y permitió que el grupo estado
islámico volviera a alzar su cabeza
durante una década más y eventualmente
establecer un califato
eeuu y los combatientes internacionales
e iraquíes han eliminado el califato
pero no han eliminado el mapa estado es
la nike que sigue siendo un problema
entre grupos terroristas confusión
política e influencia de actores
extranjeros
[Música]
irak está lejos de haber vuelto a su
estabilidad y soberanía de antaño
mira era un país que funcionaba lo
dirigía a un dictador terrible había
mucha corrupción de la corrupción pero
la corrupción que había bajo saddam des
era un juego de niños comparada con la
corrupción que existe hoy en día
no fue un fracaso
por habitante en irak es ahora cinco
veces más de lo que era en 2003
la tasa de mortalidad infantil ha bajado
la esperanza de vida ha aumentado así
que los iraquíes están mejor ahora de lo
que estaban bajo saddam hussein
aunque los grupos terroristas que han
afectado la región y a occidente como al
qaeda y el grupo estado islámico son
sunitas en washington algunos
neoconservadores siguen pensando que no
son la principal amenaza
[Música]
los islamistas sunitas no tienen un
programa de armas nucleares y tampoco
tienen un programa de armas químicas o
biológicas la diferencia
el hecho es que la capacidad para
infligir un daño máximo de mucho más
allá del horror del 9/11 mucho peor que
eso le pertenece al país que desarrolla
tanto una capacidad terrorista como un
arma destructiva y por eso irán es la
amenaza central
paradójicamente la política establecida
por esos mismos neoconservadores fue la
que reforzó a su enemigo jurado
cuando fui a eeuu john negroponte que
había sido nombrado director de la
investigación nacional estadounidense me
recibió y también me reuní con
colaboradores y el presidente bush y
ellos me dijeron bueno cada vez se oye
más que dicen que le entregamos irak a
irán en una bandeja de plata usted qué
opina y yo les dije que era que se
dieran cuenta sólo hasta ahora
los estadounidenses tenían la fuerza
tenían la capacidad tenían el dinero
para estabilizar el estadista y para
estabilizarlo alrededor de un poder
chiíta cercano y grande y que en el
fondo estaban haciendo el trabajo soñado
de los iraní cortes del hijo y cesc de
eufor bulo edición ya cité es un
desastre geopolítico mayor irak era un
país es un país que representaba la
barrera frente a las emisiones y de ahí
es todo lo que se deriva del medio
oriente hoy en día proviene de ignora si
los saudíes y los emiratíes
aterrorizados porque
porque
entonces se acercaron a israel si uno
está en abu dhabi por supuesto está
preocupado de tener aire al frente
20 años después del 11 de septiembre la
situación es aún más complicada en
afganistán que en irak
los talibanes que se habían evaporado en
diciembre de 2001 ahora controlan casi
todo el territorio y ha recuperado kabul
incluso antes de la salida definitiva de
los estadounidenses
[Música]
haciendo inversiones muy grandes
olvidamos dos cosas olvidamos la vida
cotidiana y olvidamos el problema de la
droga
si no erradicamos la droga no podemos
erradicar el terrorismo así que la doc
si no porque la droga financia y afecta
muy directamente los movimientos
terroristas que recauden sus impuestos
sobre la droga
no olvidemos que afganistán es el primer
país productor de heroína del mundo
traté de hablarlo también con el
secretario general de la onu al dolor y
debo decir que un interés en cal por
supuesto porque siempre se es educado en
revistas nacionales pero no hubo ningún
seguimiento riguroso
a pesar de la adopción de una
constitución con poder central
el gobierno afgano encabezado por ashraf
ghaní nunca logró imponer su ley en todo
el país
el exvicepresidente y unos con una
denuncia de esta situación unas semanas
antes del regreso de los talibanes al
poder
de líneas y que hoy en día no hemos
alcanzado un nivel de autonomía nuestras
fuerzas de seguridad a pesar de sus
actividades y las pérdidas no son
autónomas aunque estén apoyadas por la
población lanús y eso es también una de
las lagunas de estos últimos 20 años el
gobierno recibe apoyo y toma acciones
tampoco jota gota para comer virú anís
yo hice la pregunta
justamente a mazatlán cuando fui a
hacerle mi visita de despedida
le pregunté cómo veía la situación y
como concebía al gobierno de un país
donde el 30 por ciento de hecho hoy en
día es más eso depende porque existe el
día de la noche el 30% se escapa del
control del gobierno
y me dio una respuesta llena de
sabiduría dijo que si miraba la historia
de aprendiz tandja de hace 400 o 500
años vería que ningún gobierno ganó al
general en que el control sobre la
totalidad del país y sin embargo dijo
acá están sigue existiendo y existirá
siempre
la retirada de las fuerzas
estadounidenses decidida por joe biden
fue el último clavo en el ataúd de las
esperanzas occidentales y la sociedad
civil local 20 años después del 11 de
septiembre afganistán ha vuelto al punto
de partida
guys todavía tenemos que jugar un papel
en making para asegurar que en irak y
afganistán vuelvan a ser una base de
operaciones del terrorismo
desafortunadamente cuando nos fuimos de
irak y los chiítas tomaron el control
eliminaron a los sunitas de las
operaciones en el gobierno y en el
ejército
y los sunitas se unieron rápidamente con
el grupo estado estáticos incluir crear
una fuerza que regresó a irak
así que eeuu tuvo que regresar a irak
para asegurarse que el estado no
controlara irak
tenemos que asegurarnos de no cometer el
mismo error en afganistán la pierna
la administración bush llegó el mundo a
dos décadas de guerra
dejando centenas de miles de muertos
[Música]
al menos miles de millones de dólares
gastados países y una región que no
mejoran
[Música]
y una amenaza yihadista hoy multiplicada
de que estamos descubriendo que después
de todo una dictadura es mejor que una
guerra civil se tiene que es terrible
decirlo lo que pasó en irak
pero lentamente se alcanzaron esos
cientos de miles de muertos
me arrepiento sí señor
100 picas
porque al menos 4000 demás ciudadanos
mayores no puedo ver cuántos directores
pero el grupo estado islámico sigue
presente así que estoy horrorizada con
las personas que están asociadas con
irak y siento que es una deuda que tengo
como ciudadanos no me arrepiento lo
único que lamento es que no lo hayamos
hecho en 1991 desearía nunca haber
tenido nada que ver con eso
siento un grado de responsabilidad por
cada muerte que ocurrió al mirar aquí
del lado estadounidense del lado
británico de otros lados y los lados de
la coalición no es un buen sentido
no creo que se les siga dando
importancia a entender bien el 911 es
algo que pertenece al pasado para las
nuevas generaciones no creo que las
lecciones que hayamos aprendido se hayan
tomado en serio y la prueba de esto es
que todavía no lo estamos haciendo bien
en la guerra contra el islam radical
podría hablarle de boko haram
podría mostrarle atrocidades puedo ir a
cualquier país que quiera demostrarle
que la situación es menos estable ahora
de cuando me fui de la agencia en el
2006 no estoy bromeando a la marca de
vino heart workers
sabemos cómo ir tras los terroristas y
matarlos pero algo en lo que no hemos
trabajado es como puede venir que los
terroristas se vuelvan terroristas eso
es algo en lo que no nos hemos
concentrado lo suficiente
en eeuu no aprendemos las lecciones
hicimos un desastre y matamos a muchas
personas dos millones y medio de
personas lanzamos más bombas sobre
vietnam laos y camboya que durante la
segunda guerra mundial y no aprendimos
nada
así que la respuesta a su pregunta es
que los estudiantes no aprenden nada
deberíamos llamar nuestros estados
dobles
[Aplausos]
[Música]
a